Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is another one of those amazing papers
that I am really excited about.
And the reason for that is that this is in
the intersection of computer graphics and
machine learning, which, as you know, is already
enough to make me happy, but when I've first
seen the quality of the results, I was delighted
to see that it delivered exactly what I was
hoping for.
Light simulation programs are an important
subfield of computer graphics where we try
to create a photorealistic image of a 3D digital
scene by simulating the path of millions and
millions of light rays.
First, we start out with a noisy image, and
as we compute more paths, it slowly clears
up.
However, it takes a very long time to get
a perfectly clear image, and depending on
the scene and the algorithm, it can take from
minutes to hours.
In an earlier work, we had a beautiful but
pathological scene that took weeks to render
on several machines, if you would like to
hear more about that, the link is available
in the video description.
So in order to alleviate this problem, many
noise filtering algorithms surfaced over the
years.
The goal of these algorithms is that instead
of computing more and more paths until the
image clears up, we stop at a noisy image
and try to guess what the final image would
look like.
This often happens in the presence of some
additional depth and geometry information,
additional images that that are often referred
to as feature buffers or auxiliary buffers.
This information helps the noise filter to
get a better understanding of the scene and
produce higher quality outputs.
Recently, a few learning-based algorithms
emerged with excellent results.
Well, excellent would be an understatement
since these can take an extremely noisy image
that we rendered with one ray per pixel.
This is as noisy as it gets I'm afraid, and
it is absolutely stunning that we can still
get usable images out of this.
However, these algorithms are not capable
of dealing with sequences of data and are
condemned to deal with each of these images
in isolation.
They have no understanding of the fact that
we are dealing with an animation.
What does this mean exactly?
What this means is that the network has no
memory of how it dealt with the previous image,
and if we combine it with the fact that a
trace amount of noise still remains in the
images, we get a disturbing flickering effect.
This is because the remainder of the noise
is different from image to image.
This technique uses a Recurrent Neural Network,
which is able to deal with sequences of data,
for instance, in our case, video.
It remembers how it dealt with the previous
images a few moments ago, and, as a result,
it can adjust and produce outputs that are
temporally stable.
Computer graphics researchers like to call
this spatiotemporal filtering.
You can see in this camera panning experiment
how much more smoother this new technique
is.
Let's try the same footage slowed down and
see if we get a better view of the flickering.
Yup, all good!
Recurrent Neural Networks are by no means
easy to train and need quite a few implementation
details to get it right, so make sure to have
a look at the paper for details.
Temporally coherent light simulation reconstruction
of noisy images from one sample per pixel.
And for video.
This is insanity.
I would go out on a limb and say that in the
very near future, we'll run learning-based
noise filters that take images that are so
noisy, they don't even have one ray sample
per pixel.
Maybe one every other pixel or so.
This is going to be the new milestone.
If someone told me that this would be possible
when I started doing light transport as an
undergrad student, I wouldn't have believed
a word of it.
Computer games, VR and all kinds of real-time
applications will be able to get photorealistic
light simulation graphics in real time.
And, temporally stable.
I need to take some time to digest this.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!